[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's the popular frank caliendo comedian
impersonator impressionist all-around
good guy in
arizona cardinal die hard fan and he
joins us on the program
all right what role did frank caliendo
play
in j.j watt coming to the cardinals
i'm a facilitator dan i uh i make things
happen
it's so funny how this stuff gets blown
out of proportion uh i'm basically
when when steve kind needs something
done he comes to me i'm the ray donovan
of the nfl
that's what i am i'm like his yoda he
puts me out he
he wears me like a backpack and runs
around bagelbot that's what's going on
um i've known jj
watt for quite a while actually i've
known him
listen i'm kind of friends with him but
i'm not like great friends with them to
the point where i could ask favors of
them or something like that
but a while back uh kyme asked me uh
steve said what or actually any time a a
um
and steve time is the gm of the
cardinals just let everybody yes
okay anytime a a free agent comes up or
something like that
i'll text steve congo you want me to
take care of this as a joke
and i with jj watt uh asked for his
release he got it and i said that steve
i go do you want me to take care of this
and he's like do it do it do it i was
like
okay i thought he was joking he's like
do you text him yet i'm like
no i i have and he goes do it do it so i
just text him and it was really a soft
sell because i have you know packer fans
are mad at me
right now and i knew this could be the
thing packer fans mad because i grew up
in wisconsin
uh cleveland browns fans are upset my
wife's from cleveland
and this is what i say to those fans
your team didn't call me so
i couldn't help you uh but it's
it was good i just texted him like hey
uh
you know steve keim won't leave me alone
uh
and uh i think it would be real people
think i was like calling him his john
gruden yeah i'll tell you what man yeah
people thought i was like i'm sent like
like i do that to all my friends i can
tell you what man you think
it's uh i can see you waiting for it
like you want to go play for somebody
that isn't
me what am i going to do with the john
brood impression on that
they call him up as adam scheffner
according to my sources this is what it
appears is going to happen
you are going to sign with the arizona
cardinals
caliente is going to have people
incredibly about jay glazer you guys i
don't even understand what's going on
here guys
you guys know what it is this is this
tough stuff listen jj you're coming to
arizona i got to just pop over there
from my gym you know i'm working out
with a lot of people
i'm training mma stars listen the rock
comes to me when the rock meets somebody
you see that show
the the kid rock see i don't know if
it's called kid rock young rock rock
kid rock he plays music right as a guy
but demi lovato once knocked out me too
anyways so i'll get caliendo spot you he
can only do like 20 pound weights or
something like that
but i can i can lift the entire i can
lit you ever using a universal machine
i spot that that's a struggle so yeah it
was it was all plain and civil but
people
just keep running with these crazy
stories about uh
well you know how it is a couple years
ago when steve came
came on with you all of a sudden i
changed the nfl draft
uh and it was me just calling him
and leaving him a message or it wasn't
even that i texted him from my phone as
john grew and i'll tell you what i got a
trade idea
next thing you know after i'm on your
show people are going crazy thinking
it's
some kind of i i disrupted the draft no
no no no
it's just simple i do like the idea of
like i don't want the truth i like the
idea that you did call and just started
impersonating people
i mean that that you should go with that
frank well
that's why i'm lying a lot i set this
record straight at the end but i lie up
front and you know i called bruce
like bruce aaron's going to say hey
daddy what are you doing man do them a
favor can you give me a
tom brady i want tom brady give me give
me a crown royal give me that give it
tom brady
i'll tell you what if we win a
championship here's what we're going to
do daddy well i'll let him throw it on
from uh boat to boat
and bring in gronkowski call somebody
call belichick make that happen daddy
that's what it's all about
there's no cliff kingsbury impersonation
is there
no i don't he's he's uh he's so tall and
lean and smooth i think it would be
difficult for me to pull
anything it's easy for me to pull off an
andy reed and just do this put a
mustache on
and throw the hat on that stuff's easier
but no not really anything for cliff
kingsbury
when did you become a cardinal fan
well i lived on the same street as the
cardinals facility
so and i'm kind of wishy-washy i grew up
a packer fan
i've still got pat the packers part of
my heart but then
you know become friends with john gruden
i'm at an aerosmith concert with john
gruden you know
about 12 months ago right now uh i gotta
help
you know like i gotta root for them
because they they're always inviting me
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
how do you end up at an aerosmith
concert with john gruden
oh you don't know about that i was i was
in vegas
uh and uh i texted as the right-hand guy
jeff leonardo a nice because i'm scared
of gruden still
gruden will text me at like three in the
morning like what are you doing man
becoming frightened tinkling myself
because you're texting me
uh so he's just like they went to a
country concert the night before and
then
uh i couldn't do that because i had to
do something with my son and my
brother-in-law
who was there for a convention at the
time and then there's like he's like
we're going to aerosmith tomorrow
so gruden we get there gruden grabs his
phone he's like i'm sitting here at the
aerosmith concert with my good friend
john gruden how's it going johnny which
made me realize that
in his head gruden thinks of himself as
johnny
that's who i'll tell you what i'm johnny
lawrence i'm opening up a cobra kai
here man could you
could you full mike mayonk if you called
his john gruden
no because he they've done that you know
uh kai messed with him one time
steve sent a message he's like hey uh
gruden called me is this real
and and and mike mayok's text back to
him was nice job
nice job so yeah people people basically
know it's me
uh but at the end it's kind of funny a
lot of times
the things gruden will do he tells
everybody he loves them have you ever
heard that or know that about it like
at the end of phone calls i love you man
and then he hangs up
[Laughter]
it's just so awkward he's uh frank
caliendo the
great comedian joining us on the show i
was curious about this
to get into your craft is it more about
facial
uh than it is yeah the then it is the
the actual words you use uh yeah i think
there's a combination of things i think
it starts with
for me because there are people who do
dead-on voices some voices i do
are like right on the money some are
cartoons if i can't do it right in the
money i go for more of the cartoon
daryl hammond i think is the best i've
ever seen that can do that
just mimicry right on and get the person
exactly
i try to and dana carvey would make the
big cartoon characters right
you'd see him doing i'll think back to
the heyday of saturday live he's like
not god do it
george h.w bush never said that right
and that was something that he created
when i
when i came up with the madden thing it
was then
that's what made it feel bigger right
will sasso doing kenny rogers i'm
turning roger
you make it bigger and that's what makes
it a lot of fun so
i think to create the character out of
it yeah it becomes part of his is the
face
part of it is the the voice and then
it's what you say
as well i ten one of the things that um
recently which has a little bit of a
face is romo and nance
and they started doing me doing them i
don't know if you've
heard that but the tony romo bit is
oh jim this is incredible and amazing
and it's amazing and incredible
and right before something's about to
happen ron will go here we go jim
and it's like he's got this huge smile
like you can see him oh geez
it's really really great i can't wait to
see what's about to happen here here we
go jim and then
i couldn't do much nance so all i could
say was
one word it was tony because he was here
we go jim and
but when you do gymnastics when jim
nance gets excited it's like you're
playing
somebody's playing with the the audio
dial
and it's like into the sideline so i
would go here we go jim
so it was the bit was here we go jim
zone
[Applause]
oh jealous really really good so they
did it twice during the season
i was like are you kidding me and nance
would screw it up
so roma would go here we go jim and then
dance will go here we go no no tony
so they're imitating you imitating them
yeah yeah it must have been the crew
must the crew must do it all the time
and i started doing it the viral videos
you know somebody would fall off a cliff
remember johnny manziel
jumping off like cliff diving and oh
jeff johnny manziel we haven't seen him
he's going to be in this new league but
what's going on right now we're not sure
what's going to happen and
he's going to jump here we go jimmy
what have you been working on the last
uh year
a lot of people don't know this but i
was uh i was instrumental in creating uh
the vaccine for coven congratulations
no what have you been working on with
your show like any new
new people there's always new stuff i've
been doing a lot of
avengers things you know just the robert
downey jr do me a favor
and join me okay for loki my brother i
am loki of asgard
and i'm burdened with glorious purpose
you know just throwing stuff like that
around
uh the ba i did ba i did a charity event
with uh bruce arians a couple weeks ago
it's so funny because i had
the hat the glasses i could go grab it
right now i was actually gonna do it i
should have done that
uh but it's it's amazing how how quickly
i could turn into ba by just
holding my breath as long as i can i'm
talking about daddy
listen i know i'm off the screen right
now and you're on it yeah i know what
you're doing
isn't it listen frank just got out of
his chair to go get his
bruce aryan's hat and sunglasses or
glasses it's probably
yeah i'm a prop product i've been
hanging out with carrots up a lot
that's what i'm talking about getting it
i mean i mean that's what we're talking
about we're talking about that we're
doing that
was that stretch armstrong in front of
you there danny come on man wait wait
you do everything you got guys from the
office make it happen win or lose we
booze baby
that's what we're making make it happen
that's
that's what the game plan was and some
people said how you get tom brady i
don't know
you tell me i still get tom brady that's
how i'm smoking something that's like
that
ain't what happened dad daddy well
weed come on man i always think that
it's interesting when you're around
somebody who does
impressions and impersonations that we
feel like you can do everybody
like like yeah you know because i've
said it before you know there's certain
things
i might not be easy to do you might get
like the uh
like the delivery that i may have or the
pauses they may have like jim rome you
do a good
jim rome but jim rome gives you those
opportunities to go those are bite-sized
portions that i can sort of take
and i can make that mine yeah and rome
rome you start to feel like as a
character right he's a big guy
doing great things and you dan
patrick fight to be the regular
guy you're normal uh so yeah i think
that's
you know when you listen to stephen a
smith it's the you know
the veracity of what's going on here i
understand
everybody who ramps it up and gets to
that bigger stuff
that makes it a lot easier so um
you know and analysts are always easy
too because what do they do they break
down
people in uh in sports
so you just do that in real life if
you're doing shaq and uh
shaq and charles barkley what that's
what i thought what do you think shaq
is pretty good
i agree with the first half of what you
said shaq but the second half when you
started going to esoteric
lyricism i'm not really sure that that
applies here
i did a few months ago i did shaq with
shaq
and he came up with a new character and
it's not a political thing at all but it
was shaq
trump and he's like that's luxurious
that's romantic
shaq's doing the trump very very good
and he's like i was like that's my new
character shag trump he's like you're my
permissioner
[Laughter]
because i we we can all do
impersonations or at least we think we
can
but it's the content that you apply
to the impersonation that really
separates you from everybody else in my
opinion
yeah at times you know sometimes it just
depends on what it is and when and i
when i run out of a joke when i run out
of jokes i just go from voice to voice
and talk to myself
it's the greatest gimmick of all time
right it's just like i can create a
conversation that's what he does he just
talks about being different people i'll
tell you what man you go from voice to
voice at least oh jimmy's doing it right
now
here we go jim tony
[Laughter]
are you ever going to be able to watch
uh no no
no no no no but
how is your wife though when you're
working on your material
does that like she's never she she's
never laughed a day
in her life but around the kitchen table
are you annoying
uh has nothing to do with the voices but
yes
we've been married we've been married
for 16 17 years i i'm
truly annoying to her i think i was
annoying from the beginning it's just
she still says she came to see me at a
comedy club she was the um
the improv in cleveland and she didn't
laugh at anything i did
and it was like she was covering her
mouth because she thought i was so
terrible
and she wanted her 12 bucks back and now
we live in a really nice house and all
kinds of stuff and i'm like that's the
best investment you've ever made
you did pretty well yeah with that with
that
uh yeah leave me leave us with uh romo
and nance
and uh and and uh congratulations on
getting jj watched so
listen and if your team needs something
let me know
it's too late it's too late for that
frank too late for that
all right give me one more romo nance
before we say goodbye oh jim
it's been an incredible interview he did
a couple of voices and
we're at the beginning dan really
expected that that's what he's going to
be all about didn't turn out to be that
way but we made it to something else
and that's dad patrick being dad patrick
oh going to commercial
lead us into it here we go jimmy